all right
good morning and um
so this is joint work with
rudy basu and uh jonathan hagmon who are
both grad students here
uh let's see
maybe
really is here and
um
so
okay so let me
tell you what this is about so first
just to fix the notation we're going to
have a
a reversible and irreducible transition
matrix p
pi will be the stationary distribution
reversibility means that moving forward
or backward in time
you get the same distribution when you
start the stationarity and this is the
usual detailed balance formula which
captures that
and
to avoid periodicity issues
we'll look at lazy chains so that stay
in place with probability at least a
half
there are other
devices to avoid periodicity this is the
simplest one
and
as usual we'll measure this definition
to stationarity and total variation
distance
uh to the maximum of the
difference in probabilities between two
measures and uh d of t is the maximum
total variation distance at time t
so
um
so this is the
maximum overall target sets a and
initial points x of the difference in
the probability you are at a
versus
pi of a
okay so
so if d of t is really measuring your
distance to stationarity in the rather
demanding way
maximizing over starting point and
target sets the toleration distance
and
so the epsilon mixing time
is a time when this is below epsilon and
this d of t is a monotone
decreasing quantity
weekly decreasing so
so after that time you really are less
than epsilon
now the distance to
stationarity has a sub-multiplicative
property which means once it's
really
strictly below a half it you know
continues to go down so if you don't
care about constants then you can just
fix the eps you know constantly depend
on epsilon then you can just fix the
epsilon to be a quarter but here we'll
want to do finer things in that really
understand the dependence on epsilon but
just you know t mix
is just going to be
abbreviated an abbreviation for t mix of
a quarter when we don't write the
epsilon
okay so
so what does cutoff mean uh maybe i'll
show this first in the picture and then
go back to the formula so when we look
at the
this function d of t and i write the n
of t because typically we have a
sequence of markov chains on growing
graphs so n is the parameter here and
you know the structure of dft is once it
gets strictly below a half it has to go
down exponentially but actually the
decay could be much faster than that and
this is when we have cut off so
just to
contrast you know the two examples
that we think of the most if we have a
cycle
there's no cutoff so on the cycle of end
points
the when we run a lazy
random walk the mixing time is order n
squared but there's really no
distinguished constant that multiplies
this n squared that is
what constant times n squared depends on
how
precise you want to be what the epsilon
is so as you decrease the epsilon you
need to run larger and larger constant
multiples of n squared there's no magic
constant there
on the other hand if you look at
our other favorite example or even more
favorite the hypercube
so what is lazy walk on the hypercube
it's a very
very simple object right you have
let's see where's the eraser hiding
to the board thanks so
ah
so if we are looking at the hypercube
a simple random walk on the hypercube is
a
right so we have we have n bits that
represent our current position in the
hypercube and what is lazy simple random
walk
one step is you choose a coordinate at
random
and you don't necessarily flip it you
randomize it because we're doing a lazy
walk so you replace this bit by a random
bit
okay
so that's a pretty simple process
who can tell me what the mixing time is
how long till you mix so you have n bits
each time you choose a bit
uniformly at random and you replace that
bit by a random bit when you're going to
get close
to the station institution
what you just have to hit every bit you
just have to hit any every bit so that's
coupon collectors that's n log n
is that the right constant
well it is the right constant for
hitting every bit so n log n is coupon
collector but it's not the right
constant for our problem here the mixing
time the right constant is half so half
and log in
why is that suppose let's go to
you know to 0.51 and log in so what
happened we haven't hit all the bits
there's a little less than root n that
we haven't hit like n to the about into
the point 49 that we haven't been so
there's some there's some
so so if we look at time t which is um
you know 0.51
times n log n
then there's some subset here that we
haven't hit it's relatively small it's n
to the point 49.
the 0.49 has a plus little o of one
there but okay so that's the set we
haven't visited yet so that set should
actually all have still have has the
initial
uh setting whatever we were at but the
location of that set is completely
uniform and random so here's you know a
little observation you can see if you
take a
vector of n bits uniform
and
you know you you you pick so which is
really completely mixed and now you pick
a random subset there but it's small
it's below noise level it's below root n
so it's n to the point 49 and just
change all those say to zeros
that's still indistinguishable from
uniform it's an easy thing so it's you
know you can think of it various ways
one way is you know the binomial
distribution is pretty flat near the top
so if you move by less than root n you
really can't tell
so the mixing time is is half n log n
so uh and
and that doesn't depend on the epsilon
so t mix of epsilon is asymptotic so so
here's what happens on the hypercube is
for any epsilon
in zero one
t mix of epsilon
is asymptotic to half n log n
as n tends to infinity
and i should put an n here
because so this is on the n-dimensional
hypercube
as n tends to infinity and this doesn't
depend on epsilon so epsilon only
affects the
next order term which is order n
if you're trying i mean for the
hypercube one can do the analysis to
arbitrary precision it has been done
but uh
we we just want it as an example here
and and this is you know surprisingly
this is the second example of cutoff
this was done by aldis in 83. the first
example is actually
harder and it is random transposition so
i'll tell you about it in a moment okay
let's go back to the formula so formally
what does cutoff mean means that tmx
restaurant has an asymptotic that
doesn't depend on epsilon so one way to
say that is t mixed epsilon minus t mix
of one minus epsilon is asymptotic
uh well this is little o of t mix
okay and here i wrote t mix this is
teaming seven quarter but it doesn't
matter which constant i put here in
there
so c mix of a quarter a t mix of one
eighths they're all within a bounded
constant of each other so so there it
doesn't matter but we want that this
difference is little o of the variables
which really is equivalent to this
picture of the
um
of the total variation distance going
down quickly
and more formally you can capture how
large this is by kind of a window
so for the hypercube the window is size
n
that's what i told you so when you vary
epsilon t mix of epsilon only changes by
order n
as opposed to its order is n log n but
it varies only by n so in other words if
you look at this graph of tnft if you
put a window here of width c epsilon
n for the hypercube then you'll go from
one mass epsilon to epsilon within this
window
okay so this for the hypercube is is is
this t mixes n log n and the window
which is smaller
and order n suffices to do all the
you know all the action as far as the
operation goes
so
so just to
say something about the motivation why
do we
care about cut off let me quote dana
randall who said that you know once i
was told i just need to know if mixing
time is polynomial then
people told me well you know the power
is kind of important then i was told to
try and
see if there's a log term and now they
want me to find the constant i mean
so
it's not that we're so obsessed with the
value of the constant but but
sometimes we are but the cutoff is has
has a real meaning it captures some high
dimensional behavior and this is
something we're still struggling to
formalize
but
but there are now many theorems in this
direction that say you know mixing can
occur for different reasons and
you know the hypercube is one case where
mixing comes from you know a lot of
things have to
kind of mix you have a lot of
independent components and
enough of them except for you know up to
a noise term they all have to kind of
be randomized
you know the other extreme example is is
actually not the cycle but but this
example of a two cliques
so you have
you know two copies of kn
remember we're doing lazy walk and and
you know there's an edge between them
so this will so the random walk here
will walk
so mixing is really corresponding to
having a reasonable probability to cross
from left to right
now the event of crossing from left to
right it will take time n squared
because you have to visit this vertex
which happens only one in every n steps
but then when you're here there are n
vertices pulling you back and only one
way to cross so you only have
probability one over n to cross so it
will take you time n squared to make the
crossing but you cannot say which
constant times n squared is it
1 n squared 2 n squared 3 n squared is
actually an exponential variable that
governs
you know the multiple of n squared
and so there's only so mixing occurs
here from waiting for one rare event
so
so at a very rough thing with scale
which doesn't capture all examples we
could say that you know non-cutoff
corresponds
mostly to examples where we have to wait
for something for kind of one
rare event to happen
while
cut off corresponds to a case where lots
of things which are weakly dependent
have to go right and um
so i made one
several conjectures in this direction
back in in uh
more than 10 years ago and one of them
is that kind of in uh models where you
have a graph labeling if you are at some
kind of high temperature if the vertices
are weakly correlated then you should
have cut off and this
for the case of the easing model has had
a spectacular proof by
alan sly and the lubetsky
series of great papers that say in the
high temperature easy model
on lattices and
many other graphs you have cut off
okay
so so the first exam what was the first
example of cut off it was actually the
iconocent shashahani in 81
random transpositions so you have end
cards they didn't do a lazy chain they
did the following you have end cards one
the left hand chooses one card the right
hand chooses another card and you
transpose them so they might choose you
might choose the same card in both hands
and um
so what's the what's the mixing time
here
well
here you actually have to touch
basically all cards to mix because a
random permutation just has an
expectation one fixed point
right so if you have you know a large
number of fixed points you're not mixed
you can't allow root n fixed points you
can't allow even log log n fixed points
you really have to get the number of
fixed points down so you have to touch
all cards
each time in random transpositions each
time you are basically usually touching
two different cards so that gives you a
lower bound of half n log n
now it's
non-trivial that that's actually sharp
so it's again half n log in for random
transpositions they proved it using
representation theory
uh it took there's actually no
simple probabilistic proof uh it took a
long time to have a
nice probabilistic proof but now there
are some
uh nice ones one was found by
berstitsky sram and zetuni a few years
ago but you know no proof is very very
simple of this upper bound
anyway there's that's the first example
of cutoff it was uh you know still half
n log n
and uh and again intuitively
there should be a simple explanation
because again there are lots of things
that have to go right a lot of cards and
basically they all have to be randomized
but
this simplistic view is not been enough
to to prove things
um
and in the you know there's an
influential paper in the monthly by
aldous and dakota is 86 where they
emphasize the problem you know
understanding
when you have cut off and when you don't
and they coined the term there
okay so
well this is a spectral graph
workshops
so uh
so this is uh so one minus lambda two is
the spectral gap
and uh
following aldous will use the relaxation
time notation for the inverse gap
okay so what does intuitively the so we
know what the gap means formally but
what does it intuitively mean how is it
related to the mixing time so for
instance in the hypercube the relaxation
time is n
while the mixing time is n log n so what
does the n really mean you can think of
it as if instead of starting
in a fixed state i know that i started
some distribution that spread over say
half the hypercube and i went to ask
when does that get close to the
stationary distribution
then it's only uh the relaxation time
that
matters
so but you know when you start from one
point
there's you know you have to get out of
that corner and this is actually what
we're going to emphasize here
so
so here's one condition which is
actually easy to see that it's necessary
for cut off so the relaxation time
should be little low of the mixing time
or equivalently the spectral gap times
the mixing time should go to
infinity
so it's easy to see if this fails you
cannot have cut off so if the relaxation
time and mixing time are the same order
then there's no cutoff
and
so this is for instance what happens in
the cycle both are order and squared
and the reason is that you have an
obstruction which is the second
eigenfunction that is if you take the
stationary distribution and just perturb
it by some multiple of the second
eigenfunction that perturbation you know
just doesn't die out by the relaxation
time it gets scaled down but just by
like a factor of e
so you start with stationary you know
you have the stationary distributions
okay and you perturb it by the second
eigenfunction okay so you have this to
say the station distribution is uniform
and then you perturb it by some multiple
of the of s2 now how does f2 how much
does f2 go down
well it goes it changes by a factor of
lambda two in one step
so by the relaxation time it will change
by factor lambda two to the power
uh
you know t rel
and this is about one over e
okay so this perturbation
by the relaxation time goes down by
you know by a factor e it doesn't go
away
so if i wait for a hundred times the
relaxation time i'll just go down by a
factor e to the 100 which is still just
a constant
and so the perturbation doesn't go away
so i cannot
have cut off because if i make my
epsilon less than
e to the minus 100 then you know i have
then 100 times the rotation time is not
good enough
so it's
evident that this is a necessary
condition for cutoff and
in questions right yes so
one way the mixing time and relaxation
time interact is the start penalty
so if the lowest probability steady
state probability of
uh of a state
is little over one is that
enough to say that you in that case
the bounce we can prove on mixing time
or bigger than the bounce we can put in
relaxation
is it true also that you know it's tight
i mean
so i tell you that some states for
steady state probability is going to
zero yeah
so then look at the cycle right so all
steady states are going to zero but
there's no cut off
or look at these two clicks again
so i'm i'm not really looking at graphs
where one state has a sizable
probability so
uh
you know you can spread out i mean it's
things things are spread out but still
you know so cutoff doesn't you know it's
not that
so
okay so this is an
ethic condition for us and somehow in
all
nice non-contrived examples it's also
sufficient for cutoff but there are
these
examples
so this condition is not equivalent to
cut off and kind of the challenge has
been and still is to understand
well what do you need to add to this to
actually get cut off this is now one
thing this is a really you see cut off
if you have a lot of symmetry
you can diagonalize thing and check cut
off that's how it was done in the early
examples and then if you have other
structure like the easing model with
weak dependence then there's other
techniques but in general it it requires
very precise understanding now this
condition t rel little of t mix is much
more coarse because it's enough to
estimate both quants
quantities up to constant
so if this was sufficient then we'd be
in a happy state it's not
so we're asking is there something else
which is checkable
and we can add to it and make and derive
cutoff without actually calculating the
constants in the mixing time
um
so
so there are
you know
some examples that show this is not
sufficient due to
uh david aldus and igor pak i'll show
you how this is example in the next
slide so here's
so here's an example so here there's a
path of length
um you know
here we made it 10 n but you know
there's some flexibility and on this
path you go uh right with probability
one six left for d1 over 12 and it's
very lazy stays here with probably three
quarters
and then it gets to this point here with
probability half it goes up or down and
then it
you basically have the same chain on the
bottom and the top but on the bottom
it's half lazy and then so every time if
it moves it moves to the right
probability you know two thirds and left
with probability one third but here it's
lazy with half here it's lazy with three
quarters
so if you look at this
this chain what is it how is it behaving
it's going to so this it's easy to see
this is the worst point uh to mix
and almost all the stationary
distribution distribution grows
exponentially as you move from left to
right
so almost all the stationary
distribution is in a small neighborhood
of this vertex and the mixing time is
very well approximated by just the time
to go from x to y
but that time as a random variable
is not concentrated because there's a
decision point here and you might go up
or you might go down
you know with probability half so you
might reach from this side or from this
side and it will take you well this this
is going to take you 120
n so you move its speed 1 over 12 here
and then
on the top it's going to take you
another
you know another 12 n and if you choose
the bottom root it's going to take you
just 6n to go
left to right so
there's uh you know you get different
constants so there's no cutoff so in
particular if i look at two intermediate
numbers like 130 and 128 and both of
them the total variation distance is
bound away from zero and one
and and so
there's no cut off
uh here's a picture of how
the
total variation distance looks as a
function of time so it's
very close to one until this time 126 in
then there's some chance you've mixed
because there's some chance
um you know i should say you're mixed
you you get much closer to the
stationary distribution in the sense
that
uh all the paths that chose the fast
route the uh you know have reached the
right hand side but then it takes until
132 and between before the laggards get
to the target
and so this is the structure so this is
not cut off
okay any questions
so this is on the other hand
this is a weighted expander
so if you look at this graph because i
said almost all the stationary
distribution is here so if you have a
set of measure
you know less than a half it must miss
either this you know
basically it must miss y
uh y has about almost half the statement
or it must miss y or one of its
neighbors and then usually see that the
that you have the weight the property of
a weighted expander so this has a
spectral gap that's bounded away from
zero as n tends to infinity so the
relaxation time here is order one
also think of it if i'm starting in some
distribution which is
has not
concentrated a point but rather
on a large set now large in terms of the
stationary distribution so that
distribution has to have some mass
around here
very close to the target and then it's
going to mix immediately
so the relaxation time is little low of
the
mixing time the mixing time is is large
here it's linear in end
yet there's no cutoff
no
okay so you want to capture what's bad
in this example
this is reversible
yeah
so so that's that's the whole point so
um
so the state so the the stationary
distribution just doubles every time
so here we just added more laziness but
it doesn't affect things
and
that's the whole point i'm just talking
about reversible chains
okay and there are pax examples are also
reversible and they are actually more
more symmetric
uh we still don't know here's an example
where we don't know whether the
conjecture hole takes take a
transitive expander so like one of these
famous
lubetsky lubotsky philip sarnak
expanders any cayley graph which is an
expander so an expander we know the
relaxation time is order one the mixing
time is order login
so i conjecture that transitive
expanders all have cutoff
so this is bounded degree transitive
expanders
actually all have cut off
but um we don't know a single example
where the answer is positive we don't
know a single example or the answer is
negative
which is transitive expander if you drop
the transitivity then there are examples
going both ways
so
okay
so the key here will be to go from
from mixing time to hitting times so the
healing time of a set
is in some ways a simpler quantity we
don't ask for the exact distribution we
just ask are we there yet
and um
so there was one relationship between
hitting and mixing that was already
found by aldous in the 80s but this
was harder to use because it involved
hitting times of sets of unknown size
and uh
and so in uh
2011 there were two independent works
one by olivier and one by myself with
with
susie where
we showed that actually up to constants
mixing time can be characterized by
hitting times
but there's a catch it's hitting times
of the worst set
so
if you look at the maximum over all sets
bigger than alpha and you fix some
constant alpha less than a half
you look at the maximum expected hitting
time of such sets
maximize the you fix the alpha and you
look at the max this is equivalent to
the mixing time up to constants so it's
another way to think of the
mixing time which is
you know sometimes
sometimes useful
but this is up to constant okay so it's
not going to give you cut off
okay so
by the way this is an example that shows
that such said we fix the constant alpha
alphas to be at most a half if we talk
about heating times of sets and we
require them to be bigger than a half
then uh the equivalence breaks down like
in this example with two cliques the
mixing time is n squared but if i take a
set which is strictly bigger than a half
it's going to have representatives on
both sides and so wherever i start i'm
going to hit it much faster
in in
in order n or or even order one if it's
substantially bigger than a half
so
well the mixing time is m squared here
so it's really
a delicate point you it's important that
the target sets that you look at are at
most a half
but
why is it important in this example
because this example the product
condition fails so the relaxation time
and the mixing time here are both
n squared so one thing which is
uh
crucial is if you have the product
condition holding so the relaxation time
is little low of the mixing time in the
sequence of chains
then
it turns out that
the equivalence is much sharper
there's no loss of constants and you
allowed to you're allowed to take very
big targets targets almost a full
measure
and what this means is that the
mixing time can be related to
escape times or expansions of very small
sets
so i'll come back to that at the end so
it's really you need to control just two
things the time to escape from tiny sets
and the relaxation time and you know the
mix
okay
so so this general
question i mentioned uh was first
understood by
in the very simple case of birth and
death chains so birth in this chain is
just a nearest neighbor random walk on a
path but we're allowing arbitrary
transition probabilities
they're only to neighbors
and remember we're making it always lazy
to avoid periodicity so this is a birth
and this chain really a special kind of
chain but for these chains it is true
that relaxation time and
if the relaxation time is low of the
mixing time then you have cut off
so this was first proved by diaconas and
cell of course for a different metric
um
not toleration and then uh by
being lubetsky and myself for you know
for toleration cut off and those papers
relied on a very special property of
birth and death chains beautiful
property discovered by carlin mcgregor
in 59 which is the hitting time the time
to go from left to right or from left
from the left to any vertex here as an
exact expression as a sum of
independent geometric variables
and the parameters of the geometrics is
just the eigenvalues of the chain really
a nice
exact stochastic identity and you know
when you think of hitting time from here
to here well it's obviously a sum of
this time and this time and this time
but these are not geometrics
and these uh you know these are not as
nice so this representation is
more subtle and this was used in both of
these papers and this breaks down the
moment you move out of birth in this
chains
so
however
so one natural thing is that
we conjectured after this is that this
should still be true when you have a
tree set up
so you remember this aldous example was
based on the fact that there were two
very distinct ways to get to your target
in a tree there's only one way
and so
uh one natural conjecture is at this
extensive trees and this is now we can
now prove so the mixing time
theme exceptional on my steaming so
here's a general statement about trees
but i'll explain how it follows from a
more general statement in a in a moment
so
for any
but here's one theorem so for any lazy
markov chain on a tree
you have a universal constant c here so
that the gap between team exceptional
and t mix one miss epsilon
is bounded by this quantity so
the geometric mean of t rel and t mix
okay so there are no assumptions here
besides laziness and the fact that
this is a random walk moving on a tree
so it moves nearest neighbors on the
tree
but the transition probabilities are
arbitrary
so this is always true but if you are in
a sequence of chains with the product
condition so if the relaxation time is
little low of the mixing time
then you see that this geometric mean is
also a little low
of the mixing time and so you have
cutoff
this immediately gives that on trees the
product condition implies cutoff
um and it actually gives it's done with
sharper dependence on epsilon than the
previous works but let me say again you
can ask you know is this term sharp
is geometric mean and yes already for
birth and death change there are
examples where you need the geometric
mean in most examples like in the
hypercube
you just need the window is just the
relaxation time and in most examples the
relaxation time will do
but not all so even for birth and death
chains we have examples where the window
is this geometric mean so that's
sharp
and this log epsilon means sub gaussian
decay if you scale things up
in the window
so the log epsilon depends is also
is also sharp but i wouldn't
go into it
and
so
so where does this come from it comes
from the fact that on trees we can
understand heating times
much better than on general graphs and
so it comes from a more precise relation
of mixing and hitting so now i'm going
to leave trees for a while and kind of
get to the what's under the hood so
the same way as we defined the mix of
epsilon we can define hit
hits of epsilon so
what is this hit alpha x of epsilon so
we fix fix alpha think of alpha equals a
half so we're looking at target sets of
measure half
and we want to ask not for the expected
hitting time but really for the
tail of the heating time distribution
so we want
uh so
so this hits of epsilon is the first
time so that the probability you haven't
hit a is less than epsilon
so instead of measuring distance
in total variation we're measuring the
probability we haven't hit this large
set exactly and we're maximizing over
the starting point and over the target
set
as long as it's a big target
okay so
let's see um
so the
there's an easy spectral argument that
says that the if you start in
stationarity
and you want to hit the large set then
um you know then it's controlled by the
relaxation time so you get a bound which
is exponential
uh times
so the probability you take
s times the relaxation time decays
exponentially in s
but that's when you start at
stationarity
but this allows you to easily control
hitting times or mixing times this is
not the interesting direction so if you
um
if you control the mixing time well the
probability that you take a long time to
hit this set is certainly bounded by
well
so if i wanted
to hit the tail to be bigger than you
know the hitting time to be bigger than
t plus this 2 2 s t rel
i can just
wait for time t so that the distance to
stationarity is small
and then i have a bound on this distance
and then
with the remaining probability i can
think of myself being at stationarity
and then there the hitting time is small
just for spectral reasons
so
it means we easily can control
hitting times by mixing times but that's
not the interesting direction
this is really for completeness and the
interesting direction is the other bound
that i want to emphasize more so let's
look at
so t mix of 2 epsilon
it's bounded below by by a hitting time
but let's focus on the interesting thing
which is the upper bound
that's bounded above by
the
hit half of epsilon so remember this
means the maximum over all sets of
measure at least half in all initial
states of the
um
of the time
needed to ensure you hit the set with
probability at least one minus epsilon
it's a mouthful
but
this is what this means
and
and then there's a
correction term which involves just the
relaxation time with a log epsilon
so in the case of where the
product condition holds this is a
negligible term to the mixing time and
the hitting time so
and note there's no constants here
so there's a there's a one here okay so
this will allow you to
show cut off using control of just
hitting times
so i want to
explain the key ideas to go to the
interesting inequality here
let me first state abstractly you know
what this implies so we have an
equivalence
between cut off which you want to
understand
so the second thing is hit alpha cut off
for some alpha
in half one and the product condition so
what i said if you have the product
condition
then
you could take the
alpha in the target to be
arbitrary but if you don't have the
product condition i need to still
require alpha to be in zero half
otherwise i have this uh
kind of two click
issues
okay but anyway this is the abstract
theorem the key to this theorem is
really this this inequality
so where does this inequality come
before the
before this work all the
estimates relating mixing and hitting
were based on an idea of aldus using
uh in a very clever way stopping times
but now
that somehow inevitably led to loss of
constants
and now we have a different technique
based on maximal inequalities
and this is what i want to
kind of publicize so
here's uh
so again notation so p is a matrix so
you can think of it as a as an operator
on functions so p to the t f is just the
expectation of f t steps into the future
and uh okay uh and then
we have
e with respect to pi variance with
respect to pi are going to come in
okay so this is one
standard thing i just write down for
notation so as you take the indicator of
a set a or in fact any any function but
here we want um
to take the indicator of a set and see
how the variance goes down in time well
if this is governed by the
second eigenvalue so in other words
remember that one over t rel is the
spectral is a spectral gap so this is
just the standard spectral formula for
how the variance goes down but here is
something
less standard
so this is a inequality going back to
the 60s but as far as i know you know
we in the markov chain
community
haven't been using it and and it's
and now that i'm more aware of it i
found you know
with co-authors several distinct uses
so this is
really powerful fact so take
any markov chain here uh any reversible
markov chain i'm going to throw in the
laziness
which
simplifies things a bit
and so what is the maximal function so f
star of x
is the
so we take p to the k f
this multiple and we maximize over all k
into the future
okay this is a much larger function
but it turns out not so much so
if we take it take any p
bigger than one and we take the lp norm
of this
then it's bounded by
q times the lp norm of the original
function remember if you fix if you take
a fixed time then the operator is a
contraction in any lp space so the norm
always goes down but here we're not
taking a fixed time we're maximizing
over all times and we only lose a
constant and the constant is not too bad
so in this work we just need to take p
equals two but in other places we need p
uh more subtle
and here
so p so for p equals two what this means
is the l2 norm of this maximal function
is just bounded by twice the lp norm of
the l2 norm of the original function f
it's quite remarkable
so this was first proved by
by stein in 1961 with the worst constant
and
and then
uh
norton star proved this
in
66 with the with this right constant uh
and um
in the martingale argument now his
theorem is much more general so in our
paper we added
you know a
short proof which is basically extracted
from his paper of uh of just the
inequality that's needed it fits in in
less than a page
but i won't do it here
so how but i i do want to explain how
this gets used
let me let me just quickly mention that
we have uh
have with uh different courses really
two two soda papers that
where this inequality is the key tool so
one is this one i'm telling you about
and the other one i mentioned in the
abstract probably won't have time to go
into which is bounds for surprise
probabilities for markov chains
okay so
so how do we use this inequality so
let's write sigma s for uh just for the
natural bound of the standard deviation
of the indicator of a when we move to
time s
now let's look at the set g with a set
of good starting points for a
so in what sense are they good
so these are points starting points g so
that when i look at time s or later then
the probability
p
gs of a minus pi of a is less than these
four standard deviations so if i just
had s here instead of s tilde this would
be kind of immediate from the standard
spectral
theory
but it turns out it's very important
that we have this control
for all
s bigger all is still the bigger than s
so first i can always make this
definition and when i say it would be
immediate what do i mean if i just had s
here then
the set g that i defined this way would
be huge
it's easy to see but because of the
maximum inequality this set will still
be large when i have this much sharper
restriction for all s tilde bigger than
s
so if we want this precision to be
epsilon
then we should take we should make this
sigma s small enough so we take s to be
t real times log four over epsilon and
that's enough
here to to get that to get that
precision
okay so this is the time s will take
and then uh we'll get this property
and the key thing is that g is large
more than half the
space so this is something
my point is if i didn't have estelda
here i just had s this is easy
but the fact that it's true with this
tilde which is important where is where
the maximum quantity gets used and this
is the whole proof so you look at this
function fs which is the push you take
the indicator of a subtract its mean and
push forward as time steps okay so this
is a function f that depends on s
and now the bad set the complement of g
if you think about is exactly the set
where the maximal function not of f but
of fs
the maximal function of this
should be bigger than you know four
times the the norm of
fs
let's just follows from the definition
where we have this maximization for all
is still bigger than s and then
star's inequality tells us that
well first of all use markov inequality
to say the probability of this is
bounded by uh you know the norm squared
of this divided by
you know by by this squared and and you
get the bound
the probability of g complement is even
less than a quarter here
any questions
okay maybe an impression can you tell me
again what you required from the markov
chain here because there's no parameter
i always expect to see some number
related to the markup chain appearing
here that's not appearing in this star's
inequality so that's that's that's the
key
right
so where you needed lazy absolutely i
assumed lazy
and
irreducible and reversible and that's it
yeah but lazy is not crucial you can
double the constant otherwise so the
the way that it's phrased you can get in
continuous time without any as it is
and then for the squid without laziness
then you have it for even times okay
that's the the material
so you can get all times by multiplying
the constant
laziness avoids that okay
and to make sure i'm getting the norms
right these are not normalized by the
stationary distribution they are they
are okay
then i'm happier okay so all the norms
are norm was divided by the stationary
distribution the two norm take
everything
so
so there's no infinity norm here
there was on the previous side if i made
p equal to infinity right no he was p
was finite p was
bigger than one is strictly less than
infinity and on the right hand side
yeah so so this is but
okay so the
actually the infinity norm case is
not it's not interesting here but
so think of the l2 norm is what we want
here
okay
so this is inequality this set is large
so how does this get used
so i claim that t mix of 2 epsilon is
less than this hitting time plus
this correction term
so remember the definition of g and the
definition of s s is t real time the log
of 4 epsilon
so first look at t which is this hitting
time
because the set g is bigger than a half
i know that
i'm very likely to hit g by time t
okay in fact the
probability this is fails is epsilon
there's no steps on so now
we want to show that t plus s is a good
bound for the mixing time so you want to
compare for any set a the probability of
a at time t plus s compared to pi of a
so how can we bound this
it's in fact enough to bound it from
above
for all sets a
even without the absolute value
so
so how do i bound this i look at two
cases one case is that the set g has
taken me an inordinarily large time to
hit bigger than t well this is very
unlikely this is less than epsilon just
by the
fact that
g is large it's bigger than a half and
the definition of t t is large enough so
that any set is that large is going to
be hit by probability one man with
probability at least one mass episode
so
so we know this is controlled by epsilon
and the other possibility is that
i have hit g by time
t but i don't know exactly when sometime
less than t right
and now
my target time is t plus s
so how much time do i have left
from my hitting time of g to the target
time
well it's something at least s i don't
know exactly what but the maximal
inequality or the definition of g
exactly controls all times s tilde
bigger than s so whatever time i hit
g in if it's less than t
until t plus s i have some remaining
time which i can think of as an s till
bigger than
s
and
this hitting point i think of is g and
then
but now i know that from g
to in this remaining number of steps as
tilde i'm very close to
stationarity just by the definition of
capital set capital g
so that's it
this is this is bounded by epsilon this
is bounded by epsilon so this total is
bounded by 2 epsilon and this is what's
true for any initial point x and any
target set a so maximizing over these i
just control
x of 2 epsilon and we have you know this
term is here
and
and this term
was here so that's how we chose
um
so so in other words this s
right s was chosen here to be this and
large enough to ensure that this term is
less than epsilon
okay
any questions
this is the key general inequality and
now i can just quickly explain you know
why is this used for trees and how is
this used for trees i won't go into that
in great detail
so there are two things that help us in
trees one is we can identify essentially
what are the worst sets to hit which in
general is hard
but for trees there's always a central
vertex
so let's maybe start in the birth and
death chain what's the hardest set to
hit
it's very easy so the hardest starting
point is one of the end points either
the left or the right i have to test
both of these and say if i start from
the left then the hardest set is just
you know
this
i just take enough where
this is large enough to capture half of
the stationary measure so really in the
birth and death case i just have two
candidates to check either i start from
the left and it's the
you know the right half interval or i
start from the right and it's the left
half interval and one of these is the
worst
pretty easy to show
now there is an analog of this for trees
so
every tree has a central vertex
so let's see a picture i don't have it
here
okay so maybe
here's the picture so a central what's a
central vertex a vertex when you remove
it
then all the connected components that
result are less than half the tree in in
stationary measure
so remember stationary measure here is
just proportional to the degrees so in
other words when i remove the vertex and
now count edges in each of the resulting
components they're less than half the
original trees
we also consider a weight
so
so this is for of course
uh
this is for um that's a good point so
this is for
trees which are with uniform weights but
of course the point of the theorem it
just doesn't apply just to these trees
but to all
um to all weighted trees and then the
stationary distribution is well given by
those weights
so there's always a central vertex
you can that's a
easy combinatorial exercise and they're
at most two
so and they're neighbors
so so you can always so fix one called o
and that's the root
and
and basically
the worst
he said hit is always what's hiding
behind the central vertex
if i start from some
node
um
you know then
i'm in some component and when i remove
the central vertex i have all the other
components in front of me there they
should be at least a half
and
the
up to a small correction that's
basically the hardest sets to hit
and so that's one thing we know and then
the time to hit that set is controlled
by the time to hit the central vertex
so now we've reduced the problem of
hitting an unknown
set to hitting a specific vertex
which is general much easier and on
trees it's even easier because i know
that my path
to a given vertex is is a specific path
so the time the way i get there is just
summing the times along the path so it's
basically a one-dimensional situation
which can be controlled
now there's one more point i want to say
about that which is
here is a central vertex and here is
some
vertex
that i want to go from and suppose that
this stationary measure hiding behind
this vertex is already substantial
then i want to say that the heating time
from here to here is small
and the reason is that the heating time
from here to here is bounded by the
hitting time from an average point on
this set
and we already discussed that if you
start at a large set the heating time
the mixing time the heating times are
all controlled by relaxation
this is again using the tree structure
okay and maybe i'll skip the rest of the
details for the tree
and go
beyond trees so in this technique we can
go beyond trees and allow
for
chains that have some rough tree
structure for instance suppose you have
fixed some constant r and you're only
jumping distance
bounded by r
then it's the theorem still holds that
uh when you have the product condition
then you have cut off
so this wasn't even known in the case of
a one-dimensional chain so the methods
before were so sensitive that they
really depended on the nearest neighbor
but now we know that if you you know
your jumps are bounded by five and
okay there's some lower bound and the
transition probabilities within this
distance five then uh you have cut off
when you have uh the product condition
uh one kind of big
big challenge is to understand how far
this can be weakened so one possibility
is that really the origin of cutoff is
in approximate tree structure in very
general chains but we don't we don't
know that
um okay so
so here we have something so expansion
of small sets
uh or escape time from small sets
together with relaxation time really
bounds mixing so here is one inequality
close to what i wrote before but not
exactly the same so here the point is
here i'm looking at hitting time of the
complement hitting time of very large
sets so it's really escape time from
tiny sets so i can control the mixing
time by combination of two things one is
the relaxation time and the other is the
escape time from tiny sets
this is something we didn't know before
um
and so this is the last slide
uh
so in general so here are some
challenges here
can you understand what are the worst
sets to hit in a more general or other
settings
so for instance when you have
a partial order or the sets monotone
we we don't understand that
are the hardest
small sets to escape balls well the
answer is no but is it roughly true
we don't know
maybe when the i mean under some
strong assumptions on the on the chain
it's a positive graph
when it's not always true but in many
cases the worst case to ex
the hardest sets to escape are spectral
given by the second eigenfunction
can you characterize you know when that
is the case
okay thanks for your attention